[Music]
all right so you know how these
companies are always trying to be super
secretive like especially in this world
of tech these companies spend millions
and millions of dollars on research and
development to create innovative new
things and improve their products so the
last thing they want is some of that
research and development to get leaked
out for the competitors to use for free
and then it also represents a loss of
control of their own narrative so i've
talked about the the story of the iphone
4 prototype that was lost at a bar
before the iphone 4 came out and then
apple going through everything getting
the police involved to get that thing
back obviously you don't want people
starting to take apart and expose the
pieces of what you've built but also
seeing a product like that finished and
these new features and this new design
before apple gets to officially unveil
it the perfect way they want to
themselves is like their worst nightmare
so companies like that put up all kinds
of walls to safeguard against any
secrets about future products getting
out
they just don't want it getting out and
that can be anything from like physical
walls like i'm pretty sure we'll never
see an iphone prototype in public
outside of a certain room probably
underground on apple campus ever again
but also they can make employees sign
ndas so they're literally not allowed to
talk about stuff you know i've
interviewed business people on this
channel too and one of the most common
questions i get is do they get to see
the questions beforehand and the answer
is no but there is typically sometimes
like a list of topics that are off
limits for that interview and by far the
number one off-limit topic for these is
yeah we don't talk about future products
now there is something called the
streisand effect where the more you
attempt to hide something the more
attention it actually attracts and this
absolutely applies here and i also think
really it's the basic law of supply and
demand but really there's so few
actual real
significant leaks in tech especially now
that anytime there is one
it's a really big deal there's a lot of
demand for it a lot of attention on it
that's kind of the way it works so
there's a whole ecosystem of publishers
that will take anything and everything
that it considered new information and
publish it just anything new maybe it's
not a leak maybe it's an update on
something like maybe some new product
that was already announced is just now
being seen in stores for the first time
or someone somewhere spotted the new
packaging for a new product or something
just something literally anything new so
anyway all that is background to maybe
the weirdest newest trend that i've seen
it's not brand new but it's been
happening and it's pretty crazy which is
flying drones
this might be the weirdest way of trying
to discover company secrets that i've
ever seen so on youtube there's endless
videos already of people flying drones
all over company properties around
headquarters and around their factories
and everything now is this super cool
sometimes
yeah sometimes it is but is it also
super sketchy sometimes
yes absolutely and you know number one
it's easy to crash a drone that's like
the obvious part but number two even if
you are a skilled drone pilot
there are lots of restrictions
to what makes it legally
okay to fly a drone somewhere like if
you've ever fired up a dji drone for the
first time you get all the warnings you
know you can't fly them within five
miles of an airport you're supposed to
keep them at or below 400 feet keep them
in your line of sight don't fly them
over groups of people or over stadiums
or sporting events or anywhere near
emergency response efforts like fires
but that's all just
legal restrictions like the faa has made
the rules about what you can and can't
do in the air technically legally you
still can fly a drone over apple's
amazing 5 billion
circular spaceship building
but they absolutely will not let you do
it i've looked this up according to some
droning hobbyists on youtube who have
been doing it for a while while it was
being built they apparently hired people
to go around stopping people from flying
drones anywhere near it which is totally
understandable there was some footage of
it being built it was super cool to see
the time lapse and progress of the
headquarters coming to life but then as
soon as people started working in it it
was time to stop and then on the other
side of that spectrum there's
tesla
who
doesn't seem to care at all like
at all and so now it's gotten to the
point where it's actually kind of its
own like small sub genre on youtube
already people routinely fly over the
gigafactories that are being built every
day to observe the progress on how fast
they're being put together there's a
whole article on someone who
specifically flies over the texas
gigafactory as often as he can so often
that people who work there sometimes
wave at the drones and they're totally
cool with it and people are seemingly
constantly casually flying drones over
the fremont factory and design center
just just pointed cameras at stuff and
honestly it's usually not that crazy
like they don't really find anything too
newsworthy but when they do
then it's yeah instant news headlines
the ecosystem springs to life i actually
remember a little bit before when tesla
model s plaid deliveries started
you know that was sort of a question of
when were they going to start and in the
days before that somebody flew their
drone over the fremont factory and there
was a delivery truck in a parking lot
with a bunch of cars on it and they flew
close enough to those cars to look down
inside of them and some of them had
yolks instead of steering wheels
boom instant headlines tons of new
articles written just about that by the
way tesla model s plaid review finally
is in the works it's warming up we're
gonna start shooting car videos again so
make sure you subscribe to see that when
it does come out that's right below the
like button but now the latest one is
someone flying over the fremont factory
who spotted a cyber truck out in the
open getting worked on a couple days ago
sporting a few additions that we didn't
see on stage including real mirrors
seems like this is getting kind of
ridiculous here's the thing
tesla
is fine with this
and you know the people are definitely
pushing the limits and it's a little
creepy and a little cringe sometimes a
little bit over the top but as of right
now tesla's fine with this and really
what that seems to come down to is
tesla's obviously a weird company in a
lot of ways but one of the unusual
things about them is they don't have a
pr department and they obviously don't
run any ads like anytime you see tesla
compared to other companies usually the
number one thing they bring up is well
tesla spends zero dollars on advertising
so other companies spend a lot of money
on r d but they also have to set some
money aside millions and millions of
dollars for advertising tesla doesn't
spend a dime on any ads so hey they get
to spend even more on the product itself
now this approach is fascinating because
it has its upsides and it has its
downsides the upside being
that it's free and it turns out with
tesla specifically like relying on tesla
fans to spread the word about their
products is very powerful and like word
of mouth and the company's product
speaking for itself seems to work really
well for them so that's the upside the
downside is
that represents
a major loss of control you don't have a
direct control over how exactly people
are going to be seeing your products for
the first time so that's a calculus
pretty much any company can make
theoretically clearly companies like
apple are going to side on control they
firmly want as much control as possible
especially over their image it's
precious but tesla has uh decided to
take the risk and give up a little bit
of that control so this cyber truck just
sitting out in the open part of an empty
parking lot getting worked on in broad
daylight i would argue that this choice
is at least a little bit marketing i
mean think about it they're aware of the
drones and they have been clearly it's
been happening for years and they also
have indoor space where if they really
wanted to do anything secretive they
clearly could this is the same company
that kept the roadster and the model y
and the cyber truck a complete secret
before the events were unveiling them on
stage and tesla could control the
presentation so now they've chosen to
roll the cyber truck out around new york
city streets a few times and around
california streets for a few weeks after
that and they chose to roll it up here
right in the middle of this parking lot
to work on it on the outside in the
daylight here come the drones and here
come the articles my only thing is
please don't ruin it for everyone that's
the main thing i see when i watch these
videos like clearly there is like apple
for example
has seen that they don't want the free
pr of like people flying drones over
their headquarters because the cons kind
of outweigh the pros that free pr
doesn't really do much for them but the
negatives are like okay what if
something goes wrong what if it falls
they have to hire someone to like
collect all the drones off of the roof
of their mega wattage solar panel array
but tesla right now is one of those
unique companies that's in a position
where they're willing to deal with that
because the upside is pretty good for
them and they lean into
that hype they lean into the people
talking about their unreleased products
and all the tesla blogs writing all
those articles keeping the hype train
going now still all it takes is one
person to mess it up for everyone the
cybertruck video is already pushing it i
think and you can see the engineers
working on the truck whatever they're
doing they notice the drone and they
don't seem too bothered by it but it
just takes one person flying too close
to have a drone hit a power line or clip
something to fall out of the sky hit
someone's windshield whatever just all
it takes is one thing for tesla to flip
a switch
and decide to stop allowing it which
would be rough for that ecosystem look
if you look on a map the tesla design
center is literally six miles away from
lax and flying a drone within five miles
of an airport is already legal i don't
think it would be too hard to get a
little extension if they wanted to but
for now we're in this nice little
goldilocks zone where it's no big deal
when we get this little this little sub
genre on youtube and it's a win for
everybody involved currently just
just don't ruin it for everyone
thanks for watching
catch you in the next one peace
[Music]